our house approach was to develop model
for SOTA based on the idea of a
laboratory or creating a place where
research can be done creative world can
be made the results of this creative
work communicated between students
between teachers and students between
school and surrounding urban fabric and
between the school and a wider community
you
it is our practice and philosophy to put
our very best effort to every project we
do not have be these projects every
project and every client and user is
important to us
designs are key for us affect change and
improve our daily lives almost
everything we see and touch has a design
element good design raises our quality
of living improves efficiency widens our
perspectives and still awareness and
brings comfort and delight
you